as downing street staff gathered for
wine and cheese the people of blythe
were in tier 3 soon to be in full
lockdown
everyone here was expected to play by
the rules during the darkest days of the
pandemic
it shouldn't have happened it should not
have happened basically if we were in
lockdown then everyone else should have
been in lockdown
totally disagree with that
everything it should not have happened
put your hands up who hasn't broke a
rule i think everybody's broken well
may as well i think
they should lead the way yes for sure
they tell you what to do one thing
they're doing the opposite it's one rule
for them in one room for us those people
that were told they couldn't see their
relatives
eventually they died without saying them
i think that's where the story really
goes to to be quite honest i think
there's more important things for people
to be worrying about is something that
happened last year
i think they should be focusing on this
year
blyth turned conservative back in 2019.
the people who voted tori here said they
were willing to give the party a chance
after years of labor loyalty but could
events in downing street last year
damage that trust
could it really be toxic enough
to change how people might vote in the
future
the prime minister has been to blythe
he's promised railways and jobs
determined to keep constituencies like
this one from turning back to labor
did you vote for the conservatives in
the last election
and what do you think about that
actually i wish i hadn't
i wish i hadn't you're a regretful
conservative voter i am and does this do
the shenanigans in
downing street if they're true would
they change the way you would vote next
time yes definitely
definitely they should just draw a line
under it and move on and get on with it
i mean there's so much to do
so much
problems to solve for everyone i mean
really
we're worried about a party i don't
think so
you think it's some of my stuff sorted
out the hospital appointment sorted out
i'm not i don't really care what they do
in downing street frankly
there's a mixed view here perhaps for
good reason a lot rides on the
government delivering on its promises
people here will have to decide if a
party in the past is more important than
securing a better future nick martin sky
news live